i'm trying to get my wife to go where i
want to go to dinner because i want to
go to cheesecake factory the finest
establishment in the land if i say hey
babe you want to go to cheesecake
factory she might be like well no i
don't want to go to cheesecake factory
or like i'm not really sure now if i
switched that and i said would you be
against going to cheesecake factory well
i'm not against going to tca faction i'm
like great let's go that's the beauty of
a no base question see how different
it's phrased and if i say hey you
excited to move forward today that's a
yes right it's harder to get someone say
yes i'm excited before today would you
be opposed to moving forward at the end
of the conversation no i'm not opposed
to moving forward great and we get the
sale the psychology behind this is that
people feel safer saying no people feel
like they retain their autonomy they
feel like they're at ease especially
like you think about decision fatigue at
the end of the day people don't want to
be responsible or anything they don't
feel vulnerable to saying yes and
agreeing to something right instead they
prefer to say no and stay safe but if
you phrase your questions properly you
can get people to say yes by saying no
which is one of the most powerful sales
tax